hey youtubers is Charlie so we've got a
whole bunch of Deadpool to New Mutants
x-force x-men stuff to talk about
we got a teaser for New Mutants already
the Deadpool riders have explained
what's going on with cable how they're
going to spin-off x-force there is going
to be a Deadpool giveaway that I'll
start all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a Deadpool related
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything and I'll announce the
winners at the end of this so number
four there are two x-men movies that are
getting ready to film in Vancouver soon
in addition to Deadpool - later this
year one of them is New Mutants we
actually know a lot about this because
it's actually like a real thing we know
about the characters we know Maisie
Williams is supposed to be playing
Wolfsbane it's not a huge surprise there
was even an animatic teaser in the style
of the Deadpool test footage that
they've already released so this has
been a thing for a while but if you've
never heard of the new mutant it's the
name of the comic book the Deadpool in
cable both debuted but way back in the
80s Chris Claremont big x-men writer
wrote this spin-off comic for a bunch of
teenage characters so you have to
imagine the main x-men team is like the
adults Jean Grey Cyclops Wolverine those
are the adult characters doing the
really big stuff there's a teenage team
they went off into the New Mutants comic
book but then cable came along and it
turned into something else which I'll
explain because that comes back around
to Deadpool - but the very first
newman's roster was cannonball karma
mirage sunspot and Wolfsbane for those
of you keeping track of the timeline
x-men apocalypse took place in the 80s
New Mutants is supposed to take place
the decade after that in the 90s which
is also kind of a big deal because
Deadpool and cable both debuted in the
New Mutants comic book during the early
90s so here's the New Mutants animatic
teasers that they released I'll explain
what's going on in this after you guys
watch it
[Music]
so what you're seeing here is magic
Wolfsbane and cannonball fighting demon
bear
so demon bears one of the big villains
from their comic book it implies that
demon bear is going to be one of the
villains of the movie if not the only
villain we don't really know how many
other characters are going to put in the
movie besides this initial roster but
the current rumor based on how fast
things are going is if the movies going
to come out early 2019 it could come out
during 2018 but number three next big
thing the super secret x-men movie that
no one is talking about called x-men
super nova this is the rumored Dark
Phoenix movie so recently people started
to notice that there was a Fox movie
titled x-men super nova scheduled to
shoot in vancouver around the same time
that new mutants was going to be
shooting fox just really likes to shoot
their movies in vancouver so people are
like what you know nobody has talked
about this what is super nova what does
that mean so the current thought is is
that that's just an easter egg for the
Dark Phoenix saga there's all kinds of
questions it could be a number of
different things they've said nothing
beyond the fact that they're doing a
creative reboot of the x-men franchise
at Fox Bryan Singer is out but Dark
Phoenix is like the next big arc that
they've been ramping up for they teased
it at the end of apocalypse so even
though I didn't really think about it
this way they called x-men apocalypse
the final film in the first-class
trilogy meaning this new supernova movie
would be like something different going
forward it would look and feel just a
little bit different even if some of the
characters are the same so aside from
the characters that you absolutely have
to include in a Dark Phoenix saga like
the main x-men they said that Michael
Fassbender James McAvoy and Jennifer
Lawrence are still negotiating to come
back so you absolutely have to have
Professor X in there somewhere
but do not be surprised if magneto and
mystique take background roles I would
be totally fine if they did that I don't
feel like they absolutely need those
characters but the actors are so big
that I feel like Fox's having a hard
time figuring out whether or not they
want to include them because they want
people to go see the movie so they're
just trying to figure that all out we
can start freaking out about Dark
Phoenix
once they start talking about it I would
expect by comic-con this year they'll
have some more news about that but
number two the x-force movie which is a
little more real at this point than the
Dark Phoenix saga because the Deadpool
two writers have been talking about how
the Deadpool franchise is going to give
birth to x-force which makes sense for a
number of reasons x-force was always a
more adult hardcore version of the x-men
comic book so given this a tone of
Deadpool is both like really funny
really hardcore it's just a lot easier
for them to introduce the idea of
x-force in that movie now it could be
Deadpool 3 just depending on how fast
their plans for x-force end up happening
but the other big reason why Deadpool is
so important for x-force is because
cable was a founding member in cable is
going to be appearing in the Deadpool
sequel so you can't do x-force without
cable you can't do cable until he shows
up in the Deadpool sequel so one thing
at a time the writers said they're not
going to stuff too many characters in
the Deadpool sequel so don't worry they
could always push their plans off to the
third Deadpool movie issues you have to
imagine like some of the cooler x-men
characters slowly coming into the
Deadpool x-force universe
so like Psylocke would be a really great
candidate she was a big member of
x-force in the comics she was a
character in Xmen apocalypse who was
kind of cool but really didn't do that
much she didn't have that much dialogue
so you can put her in an x-force movie
she can be way more hardcore she's a
total badass it'll be a lot of fun I
would expect to hear more at their Comic
Con presentation just like the other
x-men film Deadpool is like the big
marquee thing now so anytime they make
big Deadpool announcements expect to
hear them include stuff about the other
x-men film but here's where we get to
cable stuff because cable forming
x-force was this really complicated
thing that formed out of the New Mutants
title his backstory is kind of a
nightmare of continuity so the Deadpool
rider says that they have a really
interesting way of streamlining that
just in the way they streamlined
Deadpool's origin story so number one
Deadpool 2 getting ready to make a
couple really big announcements right
now they have an Oscar campaign that's
going on right now I'll play that funny
trailer in a second but Ryan Reynolds
says that they're still looking for
their cable because he's so important
but there are rumors
they've already found Domino so they'll
probably announce Domino first then
we'll hear about cable really really
soon the cable stuff though so for those
of you that have read the comics most of
you that have read Deadpool know at
least a little bit about cable so they
start out as enemies that eventually
become friends the two of them together
formed this really perfect comedic duo
cable is the most hardcore man of action
in Deadpool just does not give a crap
about anything he has really good hard
on him but he just will not shut up so
they kick ass together but it's
something of like a buddy roadtrip
comedy the origin story mess cable
himself is the son of Cyclops in a Jean
Grey clone called Madeline prior the
story of how they got together is
totally crazy but then eventually cable
gets cloned his clone grows up to be
strife and is used by apocalypse and mr.
sinister to lead this force against
humanity so cables big thing is that he
comes back into the past to train a team
of new mutants in the New Mutants comic
book that become exports to fight his
clone in the future so already that
sounds like a bit of a nightmare of
continuity the x-men films already have
enough problems when it comes to
continuity so what they'll probably do
is still make him the son of Cyclops and
Madeline prior travel back into the past
but run into Deadpool while he's trying
to do something else they butt heads
until they find out that they're trying
to do the same thing and help each other
out so if you've read the comics you
know all about cables backstory
they'll probably a lot of jokes and
Easter eggs for strife mr. sinister
apocalypse but don't expect them to get
super complicated with it they've
confirmed that Colossus negasonic
teenage witch in dopinder are coming
back so they'll probably be other
characters from the first Deadpool movie
that will come back like blind doubt
they haven't officially confirmed
everyone that's going to be it and you
may have heard about the funny trailer
Ryan Reynolds just posted it's basically
an Oscars for your consideration trailer
meaning we're probably not going to win
an Oscar but hey we did some really cool
stuff so please vote for us 600
thousands of journalists
four pairs of assless chaps 12
humiliating that it's on a cat finger
here at 117 script pages 456 at Liz what
I'm sure to know Devon magical unicorn 3
good wall and a fourth that's broken did
I need to Stover 42 rejection letters
from Fox in one week video and 783
million fans for your consideration fake
laugh hiding real pain Deadpool it was a
long shot that they would have won a
Golden Globe it's an even longer shot
that they would do anything at the
Oscars like Deadpool totally does not
belong there but what they did was so
amazing that they deserve to be
recognized so I love the way they're
spinning this for more PR for the
Deadpool sequel there's new legion new
logan movie wolverine stuff that i want
to do so i'll try to update people on
what the video schedule is as I post new
videos Game of Thrones is going to be
next but I'll try to get through all the
other stuff as fast as possible well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for defenders behind the scenes
they're actually ramping up to that
right now and you can click here to
learn all about Deadpool Wolverine
crossover happening in the future thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight